The reason we're covering dirty data is
to get you to think about what to look
for in your data sets.
Then we're going to
cover how to clean or
deal with the data before
running your analytics.
When I think of all the issues I've seen
with dirty data, I think of data that
isn't parsed properly, so it appears all
in one field instead of multiple fields.
Extra characters in data fields
that make it difficult to
use the data readily.
Because those extra characters need to
be removed before analytics can be run.
Misspelled data or
typos which can easily happen
when typing data in manually.
Duplicate data records which can happen
because of multiple data entries for
the same information.
Incorrect data, like dates that
are from, say, January 1, 1900.
This can happen when a user is working
with a system that requires a value but
none is available at the time.
So the business practice may be to enter
a certain static date that sticks out so
that its noticeably long,
like January 1,1900.
Data that doe not fit with
the expected pattern.
For instance, we might have a field
containing email addresses.
But not all of the email addresses
are in the proper format.
Like name@domain.
We could probably think of others.
But for the benefit of understanding
how to recognize dirty data and
fix it, we're going to work
on these three problems.
Data parsing, extra characters and
fields, and duplicate data.
Let's now explore the first problem,
improperly parsed data, in more detail